nevada just one of the states that have
banned red light speeding cameras but
some north las vegas residents say they
can help deter speeding following
saturday's deadly crash mary jane
belliesa joining us live in our newsroom
now with how the community is responding
mary jane north las vegas residents tell
me they would like to see more safety
measures put in place like radar
enforcement or red light speed cameras
to hold drivers accountable the speed
limit on commerce is only 35 miles per
hour but those who live in the area say
drivers are speeding twice the limit and
more david kohlmeyer is a retired police
officer he lives off u.s 95 and cheyenne
while he says red light cameras may help
it only scratches the issue above the
surface to allow people to decriminalize
traffic tickets such as the red light
and it goes to collections what's going
to happen for the future for other
people meaning that if if you're not
going to go to jail and you're not going
to get a ticket that means anything and
it goes to collections what do you think
other people going to do in the
community they're not going to care
they're going to go through red lights
nyla marquez lives less than 10 minutes
away from the crash site but says it
could have happened anywhere she would
like to see red light cameras and radar
speed signs enforced if you're in a rush
maybe you don't realize just
how fast you're going and
compared to the speed limit in that
specific area so maybe it'll help you be
like oh wow i'm going way too fast i
need to slow down a little bit a 1999
statewide law prohibits traffic remote
controlled cameras against drivers
running a red light or causing accidents
but amy davey from the office of traffic
safety says there needs to be change and
how technology can
can support both safety and road user
equity
um
and create also for our communities
a sense and a perception that government
is responding to
um responding to legitimate concerns
about
you know driver behavior
nearly half of u.s states use red light
cameras nevada senate bill 43 introduced
in 2019 would have allowed local
officials to install red light cameras
requiring the owner of the vehicle to
pay a fine however the bill did not pass
reporting in the newsroom mary jane
billy is live local now mary jane thanks
for that as mary jane mentioned about
half of the states in the country using
this technology to help law enforcement
track down speeders as well as red light
runners those are in the areas
highlighted in red on the map right now
22 states use red light cameras
including many of our neighboring states
right here in the west